HUGH THOMPSON: Welcome,
everybody.
Thanks so much for taking
the time to be here.
I'm Hugh Thompson.
BOB SULLIVAN: And I'm
Bob Sullivan.
I've worked for NBC News
for almost 15 years.
Most of that time I've spent
writing about technology and
computer hackers and virus and
the computer underground.
So I know a little bit
about this world.
But in this building, I'm kind
of out of my league.
So I'm going to turn
it over right away
to Doctor Hugh Thompson.
HUGH THOMPSON: Wow, man.
Thanks.
You usually don't show that
kind of deference.
BOB SULLIVAN: I don't mean it.
HUGH THOMPSON: Oh,
OK, all right.
That makes me feel better.
This book was a really
great journey for us.
We ended up talking to a lot
of people in a lot of
different diverse fields.
And we'll spend some
time talking
about the plateau effect.
But to begin, I wanted to set
the stage with a personal
plateau story.
And so I've taught at Columbia
University for about five
years, computer security.
Many of my students
are at Google.
So if anybody's out
there, hey.
This happened, wow, I guess,
maybe 10 years ago.
I was on a flight from Las Vegas
to Orlando which is a
pretty long flight.
And I brought my laptop there,
expected to get a
bunch of work done.
Two hours into the flight,
disaster happens, and I run
out of battery.
And I'm scrambling around,
figuring out what to do.
Luckily, the plane had one
of these in-flight
entertainment systems.
How many people have ever
flown with one of these
in-flight--
all right, yeah, pretty much
everybody has now.
Back then they were
kind of unique.
And so I pull this thing up.
Oprah's got a terrible
guest on.
Doctor Phil I just can't do.
And, finally, I turn my
attention to the games.
And these are incredibly
cheesy games.
I don't know if you've ever
played any of these things.
And one looks strikingly
similar to the classic
strategy game Tetris but
was called [? Fatris ?]
I guess for copyright reasons.
So I pull this thing up.
And I'm playing for a while,
and I'm a pretty advanced
Tetris player.
I'm sure I'm not alone
in this crowd.
And so I went to the options
configuration screen which was
ambitiously worded because
it was only one option.
And the option was how many
blocks would you like to see
in advance?
So for anybody's who has played
Tetris, you know the
more blocks you can see in
advance before they come, you
can plan because you're waiting
on that big four block
line to come down.
So it had a touch screen
control, a plus-minus control
on the screen.
And I keep hitting plus.
And the maximum value
that this thing
would take was four.
Right.
So that's the maximum number
of blocks that
you can see in advance.
And so I asked the question I'm
sure any of you would have
asked in a similar circumstance,
what can I do to
increment this value
beyond four?
Again, I had an hour
left on the flight.
And so I noticed that there was
a phone console attached
to this in-flight entertainment
system.
You know you swipe your credit
card and make $23 a minute
calls to friends and family.
So I picked this thing up and
I see that it's connected to
this entertainment system.
So I select the four.
I kind of hold it down,
it gets highlighted.
And I try and type in 10.
Very disappointing, it changed
to one and then it
changed to a 0.
Both of which are
legal values.
And so then I thought, OK, well,
maybe there's a single
digit constraint here.
So I tried an eight.
Again, very disappointing.
It didn't do anything.
So then I thought OK, one of
the most common errors in
coding is to be off by one.
Right?
So you're meant to write the
code that says this value
shall be less than five, but you
accidentally write, this
value shall be less than
or equal to five.
Boundary value testing.
So I put in a five,
and it took it.
And I'm sitting there, it's the
most excited I think I've
ever been on a plane.
I go back to the touch screen
control, and I hit plus, and
it increments to six.
Now my guess is the logic around
the plus control said
something like if four
do not increment.
Well, it wasn't four.
It was five.
So it happily went up.
So I'm sitting there in the
chair, pulse, pulse, pulse,
pulse, pulse, pulse, pulse,
until I get to 127 and pause
for a moment of reflection.
Now 127 is a number very near
and dear to my heart as I'm
sure it is for many of you.
It's the upper band of a single
byte signed integer.
And so normal math, and my PhD
is in math so I can attest to
this, says that 127
plus 1 equals 128.
But sometimes 127 plus 1 equals,
anybody remember?
Negative 128.
Right?
It will wrap around to the
most negative value.
So I think about this
for a second and
consider where I am.
BOB SULLIVAN: 30,000
feet in the air.
HUGH THOMPSON: 33,000.
BOB SULLIVAN: Sorry.
HUGH THOMPSON: Don't
undersell it.
But in the name of science,
I hit plus one more time.
The screen flashes negative
128 just for a second.
And then, proof, screen
goes black.
Proof.
Guy's screen next to
me goes black.
The entire plane entertainment
system goes down.
And I'm sitting like this
in the chair hoping that
something doesn't go
off to the left.
Now it's interesting to
think about this.
And as somebody who's done a lot
of software testing, and
I've written a bunch of books
on secure coding, a book
called "How To Break Software
Security," a
software testing book.
That is the first time
that I ever ran
into the plateau effect.
If you sit a tester down and
say, I need you to break this.
I need you to find bugs.
You find a lot of bugs right
at the beginning.
And then quickly your rate of
bug finding plateaus off.
It turns out that that plateau
curve, like the natural
logarithm, shows up in almost
every area of our lives.
And that's what the plateau
effect is about.
Why do you sometimes
get more for less?
BOB SULLIVAN: So I have not
broken any airplane's
in-flight entertainment
system.
HUGH THOMPSON: Good.
Good.
It's like a support meeting.
BOB SULLIVAN: Yet, yet.
I have an excellent
trainer, though.
HUGH THOMPSON: Don't
do it, man.
I strongly advise against it.
BOB SULLIVAN: So what was the
odds-- somewhere in your brain
you thought, is this
plane going down?
HUGH THOMPSON: Oh,
no it's not.
It wasn't.
I had faith in the--
BOB SULLIVAN: So the point of
the testing story is that,
again, if you keep doing the
same kind of things over and
over again your returns
get less and less.
And we all know those people
who have ever tried to lose
weight or body build are very
familiar with what the concept
of the plateau effect is.
It hits testing.
It hits people who try learning
to play the piano.
It hits marriages.
It hits businesses.
Things that you do that were
formally effective suddenly
become less and less
effective.
So in testing, for example,
it's a really good answer.
Testers have come up with a
spectacular answer for this
which is fuzzing.
So instead of hiring testers,
you hire piano players.
You hire random people
off the street.
And they do unexpected things.
And those unexpected things are
actually what break you
through this plateau.
But the problem is,
and it's funny--
I just met with an
old colleague.
I can't say who he was, but
he is the head of a very
important news organization.
And we were talking about how
when you stay at the same
place for 20 years or more, it's
a lot more like you're
running on a treadmill
instead of running
out in the real world.
And you can get very, very
good at running on a
treadmill, you can
be the world's
fastest treadmill runner.
But that doesn't mean you're
going to be any good at
running in the real world.
So that's the problem with doing
the same thing over and
over again.
It ceases to work.
HUGH THOMPSON: And it's
incredible, this curve, and,
again, you can think of this,
well, natural log
is similar to this.
But this curve pops
up in almost every
area of human endeavor.
If you're in medicine, for
example, this looks like the
dose response curve.
The point at which
medicine becomes
ineffective as doses increase.
If you look at somebody who's
trying to lose weight, for
example, same thing happens.
They plateau off.
So this curve, we spent three
years talking to people in
psychology, medicine, venture
capital, folks even as diverse
as cooks and culinary artists,
I didn't realize they were
called artists.
And this same curve shows up
over and over and over again.
So the question that the book
tries to answer is are there
commonalities to plateaus?
Are there sets of underlying
conditions, causes that are
the same if you're trying to
break a piece of software or
you're trying to lose weight
or you're trying to start a
business or you're trying
to get your
business to the next level?
And we spent, like I said, about
three years trying to
answer this question.
And we found that there
are these eight
causal factors of plateaus.
But talk about the book scene
and where it starts.
BOB SULLIVAN: So before we
tell you what the eight
factors are, we want to give you
another example of what a
plateau is like.
I'm sure some of you have spent
some time in your life
in the Bay Area, here.
Right?
Have any of you eaten at this
restaurant, The Stinking Rose?
You all familiar with it?
The Stinking Rose is probably
the most famous garlic
restaurant, maybe even
in the world.
Right?
Everything on the
menu is garlic.
They have garlic ice cream.
The Stinking Rose, well,
stinks of garlic.
You can smell it
down the block.
The most overpowering sensory
experience you might have ever
with your nose is walking
into The Stinking Rose.
And you walk in, they sit you
at your table, you sit down,
they hand you a menu.
And what happens to that garlic
smell as you sit there
looking at the menu?
It disappears.
It's gone.
Did the garlic all go away?
No.
Your nose just stopped
smelling it.
Your nose got what's
called acclimated.
Acclimation is a part of
all of our biologies.
It's built into us.
Our bodies are literally
designed
to ignore the familiar.
So even something as powerful as
a garlic-filled restaurant
suddenly becomes familiar and
effectively disappears from
your consciousness.
That's the power
of acclimation.
And acclimation is one of the
main causes, one of the first
causes of a plateau.
We get used to things
that are familiar.
And slowly but surely our
sensory experience of them
disappears.
If you actually plot acclimation
on a graph from
your nasal olfactory nerves,
it follows that
plateau curve exactly.
So anyone who's ever experienced
walking into a
locker room and saying,
oh this is horrible.
And then suddenly
you can bear it.
Then you know precisely what
the plateau is and why your
body is actually working against
you so that whatever
you do every day, you slowly
but surely get
less good at it.
HUGH THOMPSON: Yeah, thank
goodness for that plateau.
By the way, mention Bob and Hugh
at The Stinking Rose for
a 10% discount.
No, just kidding.
Actually, we should
set that up.
BOB SULLIVAN: That's
a really good idea.
Marketing.
HUGH THOMPSON: So what is
the plateau effect?
Essentially, it's the law
of diminishing returns.
We get less and less for
applying the same thing over
and over again.
But it's more than just that.
I think if you don't know that
the plateau effect exists in a
particular pursuit,
you give up.
You think that you've
peaked out.
You've topped off.
It's the maximum amount that you
can ever get out of this
particular endeavor.
I'm just thinking about the
shift in testing that happened
when we went from free form
exploratory testing and
automated testing
over to fuzzing.
So, of course, we
still do both.
But if you look at most of
the major vulnerabilities
discovered in software today,
they're found by fuzzing.
And fuzzing is like an
amphetamine-laden monkey,
right, that you just kind of sat
off in front of a keyboard
and hoped for the best
and see what happens.
It's because systems
are so complex.
It's very difficult sometimes
to reason through the exact
set of inputs that may
cause it to fail.
That idea of applying diversity,
or fuzzing, to
other areas of your life has,
we found, applied in things
like weight loss, things
like muscle building.
I don't know if anybody
here has ever tried
cross fit, for example.
But the whole premise of cross
fit is based on fuzzing.
Doing different things every
single day to try and get your
body surprised or shocked
into change.
So we mentioned these eight
elements of plateaus.
We won't have time to go
into all of them today.
That's what the book is for.
And the book is much longer.
Or the audio book which
is only eight hours.
So consider that for
your weekend.
It's a denial of weekend
attack--
DOW, DOW.
Or you can listen to two,
and then it's a DDOW.
But these are the eight
causes that we found.
You see immunity as the
base at the bottom.
And I think that there's a
threat of immunity that goes
through all of these.
We just naturally get used
to certain stimulus.
And we talked about
immunity already.
We talked about it in
the testing space.
We found that immunity is such
a common cause of plateaus in
other areas of our life like
sports, for example.
Still, that Derek Jeter
thing shocks me.
BOB SULLIVAN: So there's this
great story of Derek Jeter,
who I think most of you
are familiar with.
He is either the best or the
worst shortstop ever depending
on what East Coast city
you are from.
I'm not here to argue
that point.
Obviously, he's the best.
HUGH THOMPSON: Worst.
Terrible.
BOB SULLIVAN: But one
fascinating thing about his
career is that at about age 35
even Derek Jeter heard all the
criticism that he was a
particularly bad defensive
shortstop and specifically very
bad at going to his left.
And he went to this advanced
athletic training institute in
Florida where they identified
the fact that when in baseball
as a right-handed hitter, you
swing like this roughly about
2 million times by the time
you're a 35 year old shortstop
for the New York Yankees which
made his left hip lock much
more quickly than
it should have.
And it cost him about 1/10 of a
second every single time he
had to make that critical
crossover step
going to the middle.
So he worked with a trainer
named Kevin Connolly who
literally made him take
his first steps
over and over again.
It turned Derek Jeter
into a 2-year-old.
He attached weights to his body
so that he literally had
to learn from the beginning.
They deconstructed the way that
he walked and then the
way that he ran.
And the next year, he won a Gold
Glove at shortstop, the
oldest Gold Glove winner
at shortstop
in the last 50 years.
So that's Derek Jeter's story.
But I'm much more interested in
talking to you about this
graphic here.
The other part of-- my name is
Bob Sullivan so all of you
should assume that somewhere in
my family lineage I had a
cousin, aunt, uncle,
grandfather, who
owned an Irish bar.
In fact, I've had several.
So I know something
about Irish bars.
And all of you here have had
this experience, probably the
first month of your freshman
year at college, where you got
very, very drunk on a beer and
a half during orientation.
And then by the end of the
month, you needed a fifth of
Jack, a 12 pack, and
maybe a couple of
others shots of vodka.
HUGH THOMPSON: A fifth of
Jack and a 12 pack?
BOB SULLIVAN: Maybe
that's just me.
HUGH THOMPSON: What college
did you go to?
Geesh.
BOB SULLIVAN: We'll discuss
college partying later.
But immunity is seen
by all of us.
People who are in the hospital
and are there for a long stay
and have some kind of extensive
surgery, morphine
dosage goes up and up.
Because our tolerance
goes up an up.
But tolerance is related
to acclimation
is related to immunity.
And all of us have experienced
tolerance and acclimation and
immunity when drinking.
So a good thing to keep in mind,
and as we discussed at
our fine plateau party
last Wednesday--
HUGH THOMPSON: Ransom
empirical.
BOB SULLIVAN: If you're slowly
drinking Bud Lights and
starting to feel that you've
topped out and you're--
HUGH THOMPSON: If you're slowing
drinking Bud Lights
you need to leave the party.
BOB SULLIVAN: Well,
my parties anyway.
But the best way to break that
plateau is maybe goading one
of your friends into a shot of
something that breaks through
your plateau.
But that's--
HUGH THOMPSON: This is
not the takeaway--
BOB SULLIVAN: Enough
about Irish bars.
Yes.
Clearly, that's my role
in our partnership.
HUGH THOMPSON: The
second element
is the greedy algorithm.
Anybody here that has ever
studied math has run into the
greedy algorithm.
It basically says we take the
locally optimal solution.
So whenever seems like the place
that we make the most
progress immediately we take.
And we have a scene in the
book where we talk about,
because Bob and I have suffered
through this so many
times, you've got to get
20 blocks in Manhattan,
how do you do it?
Well, somebody who's following
the greedy algorithm says, OK,
look, I probably have to wait
two minutes to flag down a
cab, and during those
two minutes,
I'm making zero progress.
Or I could go to the subway stop
which might be two blocks
in the wrong direction.
In that case, I'm making
negative progress.
I'm getting further and further
away from where I'm
supposed to go.
Or if you're following the
greedy algorithm, you just
start walking.
Because instantly you're making
immediate progress.
If somebody looked at you a
minute after you began this
quest, the person who started
walking towards the goal looks
like he's made progress.
He's getting closer.
But everybody who's ever lived
in New York knows that the
fastest way to get anywhere,
most of the time, well,
fingers crossed,
is the subway.
And the subway often requires
you to make something that we
call retrograde progress.
Sometimes you have to go in
completely the opposite
direction to make a bigger
leap forward.
It turns out that the greedy
algorithm occurs all the time
in other areas too.
In business, we see it
happen all the time.
Publicly traded companies,
they're subject to 90 day
windows of performance when
earnings come out.
So if you're a publicly traded
company, you have to follow
the 90 day window greedy
algorithm.
You have to optimize
for profit.
You have to optimize for revenue
during that period
even though that may not be in
the best interest of the long
term health of the company.
So this greedy algorithm we
found is a very common reason
why people reach plateau.
BOB SULLIVAN: Meanwhile, timing
is also a very, very
important issue.
And timing gets into our lives,
of course, you can
think of comedic timing.
You can think of a
good time to have
children in your family.
You can think of a good time to
book some sales so you can
pump up your quarterly
numbers.
But timing is a really
interesting element.
This is a really interesting
time for time right now in
human history.
We spent a lot of time with a
group called the Quantified
Self Movement in the book.
Has anybody here heard of the
Quantified Self Movement.
HUGH THOMPSON: Have you ever
been to a meeting?
Has anybody here ever
Just out of curiosity.
OK.
BOB SULLIVAN: There are
chapters of Quantified
Selfers, they are called QSers,
all over the world.
One of the largest is actually
in New York.
They are in Brooklyn.
And so we went to a couple
of their meetings
and got to know them.
These are people who watch
what you guys do.
You guys are counting
everything, observing
everything that we do, big data
about the world, studying
it, maximizing efficiencies.
And they're doing that
about themselves.
So these people in the world
of a million little sensors
that are all connected, they
put sensors on their body.
They put sensors
on their wrist.
And they count how many breaths
they take during the
day, what their heart rate is
every five seconds or over the
course of an entire day.
They plot their oxygen intake.
And then they measure that
against things like what kind
of a mood am I in?
How well did I run?
A lot of them are performance
related.
A lot of them are runners
in particular.
And if you talk to any of them,
they will tell you, I
know that the best time for me
to start a five mile run is
exactly at 7:37 in the
morning when it's
between 60 and 65 degrees.
Now, a lot of this feels like
they're just enhancing their
own OCD tendencies.
HUGH THOMPSON: They were in
better shape than we were.
BOB SULLIVAN: They were
in much better shape.
It was a very intimidating
room to be in.
Let me tell you.
Yeah
HUGH THOMPSON: It's
on a high bar.
BOB SULLIVAN: But this might
seem extreme right now.
But a lot of this is becoming
more and more popular.
There's a whole technology now
called slumber tech where
people are attaching devices to
themselves and doing what
only high-end hospitals used
to do, which is seeing what
kind of a sleep am I getting.
How much REM sleep
am I getting?
You attach something to your
wrist, or you wear a shirt
that attaches to an iPhone.
It downloads to a website which
then in a week or two
analyzes whether or not you
need to sleep more.
So we are actually starting
to get a grasp on time and
figuring out is this
a good time or a
bad time to do things?
Now, timing, of course, has been
this human quest forever.
But a lot of people have
studied time in these
incredibly detailed ways.
And the one that we talk about
a lot in the book, because
there's a good time and a bad
time for things, is in
memorization.
So do you want to talk about
memorization, or do you want
me to go ahead?
HUGH THOMPSON: Yeah.
Yeah.
Sure.
Go.
BOB SULLIVAN: We can
talk about this.
And so the Ebbinghaus Spacing
Effect, which maybe some of
you encountered in your studies,
says basically this,
ever since we were little kids,
we were told there's one
way to learn multiplication
tables.
Beat it into your head.
Repetition over and
over again.
And if you went to a modern
school in the last 20 years or
so they might have said,
repetition is horrible.
It beats kids up.
It's no good.
So there's this rote
memorization, anti-rote
memorization school.
And of course both of them are
wrong and ineffective.
But what we have found
and what [? Henrik ?]
Ebbinghaus found 100 years ago
is that it's not repeating
something over and over again,
it's when you repeat it.
So there's this very specific
curve which suggests that
constant repetition
becomes very, very
ineffective very quickly.
You could sit down, I'm sure
you've had this experience,
you meet someone at a party.
His name is Bob.
I'm going to remember.
Bob, Bob, Bob, Bob.
His name is Bob.
Oh, Hugh, how you doing?
What was that guy's name?
It happens constantly, right?
And it's because it's not
effective to repeat it over
and over again.
But it turns out, if you start
to forget something and then
you remind yourself of that, you
pop it up to the surface
of your memory.
And then you do it again.
And if you do it at these very
in particular spaced
repetitions, they are different
for everybody, but
it's something like this.
two seconds afterwards, 10
seconds afterwards, a minute
afterwards, five minutes
afterwards, 10 minutes
afterwards, half an hour, two
hours, 12 hours, two days.
Picture a ball floating
on top of water.
And just as it's about to sink
below the surface, just as
you're about to forget
something, pop it back up
above the surface again.
You do that seven or eight times
in this very particular
sequence, you will
never forget it.
That's how things are burned
into your brain.
That's how our brains
are built.
It's called the Spacing
Effect.
And it's far more efficient.
You could memorize something
only repeating it 10 or 11
times instead of 1,000 times,
you might do it in a very
compressed amount of time.
So that's how you can
hack the code of
your own brain's timing.
And timing is just one example
of a whole bunch we have in
the book about taking control of
timing, studying timing in
yourself or your business or
your relationship and figuring
out when is the best
time to do things.
There a great story in the
book about a parole board
where someone examined over the
course of the year whether
or not this parole board was
likely or less likely to grant
parole to criminals,
to inmates.
And basically the results were
after lunch when they felt
like going home, they granted
parole to everybody.
The last thing in the world you
wanted to be was the first
case they saw in the morning
when everybody was focused and
really hard on the inmates.
So all the lawyers who figured
this out made sure to schedule
all of their hearings at the end
of the day, had a massive
success rate.
So timing is a really critical
factor in success.
HUGH THOMPSON: I just noticed
that so many of your stories
start in a bar.
You could have easily said when
you meet somebody at a
conference.
BOB SULLIVAN: I am
an Irishman.
HUGH THOMPSON: It's
just a side note.
So the next element that we
found in plateaus have to do
with flow issues.
And we've got a couple
of different
sections inside flow issues.
One of the biggest causes
of problems with flow is
something called erosion.
Erosion is where you deplete
a resource over time.
So I grew up in the Bahamas.
Born and raised there.
Wonderful place if anybody's
planning a vacation.
We need your tourist dollars.
But I used to go on a Easter
egg hunt every Easter.
And it was on this isolated
island just set up for an
Easter egg hunt.
And it's amazing.
As a 10-year-old, you'd find
half of the eggs that you'd
find for the entire day in
the first five minutes.
Because they are plentiful.
They're everywhere.
But as more kids start to find
more eggs, your rate of egg
finding follows this
plateau curve.
And it's interesting, any time
you're consuming a resource
that is fixed, you hit
a plateau naturally.
Because they're less and less
of those objects available.
We also talk a lot about
step functions.
So step functions are where you
have to make a big leap in
a resource.
Think about Cloud for example.
Cloud has actually
solved the step
function for many companies.
Before, to move from the step of
not being in business on a
web company to being in
business, you had to buy
expensive servers.
You had to house
them somewhere.
You had to have somebody to
run and maintain them.
The Cloud lets you take
spin up of VM, and
you're going in seconds.
And you can incrementally rent
capacity when you need it.
It turns out that same function
of smoothing things
is happening in other
areas of our lives.
It's happening in car
rentals for example.
Zipcar.
I don't need something
for 24 hours.
I just need it for an hour.
And it gets into this bigger
issue of unused capacity.
What unused capacity do
we have in our lives?
Maybe you own a car.
You drive it to work in the
morning at 9:00 AM and then
you leave at 5:00 PM.
What's happening to the car
between 9:00 and 5:00?
It's just sitting there.
If there was a way that you
could incrementally rent that
car out to someone else and knew
it would be back at 5:00.
You had all the right
insurances, all the right
protection, you trusted
that person.
You'd do it.
It's a way to monetize
a fixed asset.
And we're moving more and more
into this service economy
where we're getting
out of steps,
moving into smooth functions.
Another area is a choke point.
And a choke point, you can think
of it as the thing that
fails first.
So not to get too in depth here,
but how many people have
followed some of the distributed
denial of service
attacks against the financial
services institutions over
these last 12 months?
It's interesting to see
how many of these
DDoS attacks go down.
Before it just used to be
requests, essentially
refreshing the page.
Now a lot of the DDoS attacks
that we're seeing are
application aware.
They're actually trying to
stress out say the off system
on the back end by being aware
of the page, actually entering
characters into a user name
password field, and then
causing the off to spin
on the back end
instead of just the refresh.
And the reason for that is that
back end system that's
doing the authentication
is the choke point.
It's the place that's likely
to fail first.
And we're seeing attackers
become very aware that choke
points exist in systems.
And instead of going brute
force, they're more
intelligent about how they
look for failures.
So I want to talk about a choke
point that I'm sure is
very near and dear
to your heart.
And it's the CAPTCHA.
So CAPTCHAs are a fascinating
phenomenon of computer science.
I've known Luis von Ahn for a
long time who was one of the
creators of the CAPTCHA.
And to me the CAPTCHA
is a choke point.
Whenever I have to go into a
site, I get the user name and
password wrong three or four
times, CAPTCHA comes up.
I've got to type it in.
They've gotten so complex now
that most of the time, I can't
even figure out what they were
and have to go through two or
three of them.
But we often think about
CAPTCHAs from our perspective,
but you never think about the
pain and turmoil this has
caused for the bad guys, the
emotional disruption.
So these guys had invested
a fortune in script
infrastructure that went out and
bought all the tickets at
Ticketmaster or went
out and created
50,000 free email accounts.
And suddenly one day when the
CAPTCHA was introduced, the
scripts didn't work anymore.
Because there was a test to
see if this person is a
computer or are they a person?
But it's interesting to see how
the security community and
the hacking community,
in particular,
responded to CAPTCHAs.
The first thing that
they tried to do--
I don't know if anybody
remembers this, but the very
first thing was to try and
create optical character
recognition software to
outwit the CAPTCHA.
Couple big CAPTCHAs fell.
But still CAPTCHAs got more
and more complex.
So that didn't seem to
be a viable route.
The next option was to hire
people in low average income
countries to fill
out CAPTCHAs.
Right.
And even today, if anybody's
interested, afterwards come up
to me, and I'll hook you up
to the right vendors.
You can go on the weekend and
make a couple extra bucks by
filling in CAPTCHAs.
I think it's now up to 1/100
of a cent per CAPTCHA.
So, again, if things
are tight here at
Google, just let me know.
But even that doesn't scale.
If you have to try 100,000
password attempts, for
example, that gets kind
of expensive.
You might as well buy a stolen
credit card number for that
investment.
But then they did something
truly revolutionary to get rid
of the choke point
of the CAPTCHA.
They leveraged the
most powerful
force on the internet.
The force that included
image tags in HTML.
The force that pushed the
balance of database search and
access time.
The force that picked
VHS over Betamax.
Pornography.
So they created pornographic
servers, most of the time
specialty pornographic
servers.
And to get to the next image or
next video, you didn't have
to sign up, no credit
card required.
All you had to do was fill
in five CAPTCHAs.
That's it.
Probably very quickly.
That's my guess.
I don't know.
This is all theoretical.
But it's interesting.
Because they were getting
thousands of these things
filled out for free every
single minute.
It's a pretty sad commentary
on society actually.
But this was a solution to the
choke point problem that
really scaled.
Right.
There is no CAPTCHA, even
RECAPTCHA can't get around
this problem of a motivated
person filling in CAPTCHAs.
And what they would do is take
these CAPTCHAs real time from
the sites that they were
trying to get into.
And so they had this elaborate
infrastructure on how they
delivered the CAPTCHAs
so it was in the
right window of time.
Truly, truly amazing.
So that's one of our
inspirations in the book.
If that can be an inspiration.
And this is a less ambitious--
this wasn't like five CAPTCHAs
for the next image.
This was one CAPTCHA
per article
of clothing or something.
Appropriately censored.
BOB SULLIVAN: Specialized
pornographic servers?
HUGH THOMPSON: That's what
it said in the article.
BOB SULLIVAN: We'll discuss
that later.
HUGH THOMPSON: It
was researched.
The Colombia students told me.
BOB SULLIVAN: So another one
of the things that really
makes small businesses plateau,
we have a lot of
stuff about small businesses and
small enterprises within
large businesses.
The worst thing that could
possibly happen when you're
starting out at some adventure
is for you
to succeed a little.
And then succeed maybe a little
bit more, and then
slowly but surely whatever
technology that you have, it
kind of keeps going.
I always think of AOL when
I think about this.
HUGH THOMPSON: Oh, wow.
AOL is a blast from the past.
BOB SULLIVAN: Specifically
AOL's dial up service.
Right.
So failing slow is the biggest
problem that a lot of
companies can have.
The opposite of failing slow,
of course, is failing fast
which is what you want to do.
If you're starting
a new adventure,
you have some money.
You have some ideas.
What you want to do is touch
customers as soon as possible.
Get feedback as soon
as possible.
And find out if your idea stinks
or there is some fatal
flaw to it.
Because if it succeeds a little
and you chug along,
three or four years can go by
and next thing you know,
everybody's past you by.
And everyone's way too
emotionally invested in this
specific idea that you have.
Now failing fast was invented
really as a term by your
friend Alberto.
HUGH THOMPSON: Oh, yeah,
Alberto Savioa.
I don't know if anybody
here knows Alberto.
So he was the Engineering
Director for AdWords for a
long time here at Google.
BOB SULLIVAN: So talk about
the pretotyping.
HUGH THOMPSON: Yeah, so he had
this fascinating concept.
And he really applied it while
he was here, this idea of
pretotyping.
So pretotyping is create
a pre prototype.
Even if it doesn't work.
Even if there's humans in the
back end filling out forms and
giving you responses.
The idea behind a pretotype is
you'll quickly know if there's
a response to it by the
user community.
Pretotyping is becoming a very,
very powerful way for
startups to get validation,
for example.
I live in Silicon Valley now.
And it's fascinating the
things that would-be
entrepreneurs will do.
This one guy pulled me aside,
I had coffee with him a
couple years ago.
And he said their method for
rolling out a new product or
service is to create essentially
a storefront that
looks like the service
exists on the web.
And they wait till they get to
the point where they're asking
for somebody's credit
card number.
They let the credit
card number be
entered and hit submit.
And then it just sends them
to a 404 error page.
Because they've actually
not built the service.
But then they take and count the
number of people that have
gotten to that point and then go
to the venture capitalists
and say, hey, see how many
people would have signed up
for this thing if it
really existed.
So this idea of pretotyping is
a very powerful one in other
areas of your life too.
It doesn't just have to be
startups and businesses.
BOB SULLIVAN: And we want to
be respectful of your time.
So we know this.
We're going to leave a couple
of minutes for questions.
We just have a couple
more slides.
And then we'll leave some time
so that you can ask questions
or run off too.
I'm sure there are very
important things
that you have to do.
But just one last of the
elements that we're going to
go through, distorted data.
We just did a segment with CNBC
yesterday about a concept
we call data idolatry.
We love big data.
I'm a sports fan.
I love sabermetrics.
But at the same time, there's
all sorts of evidence to show
that people are giving way too
much credence to data which is
always backward looking and
losing the strength of their
intuition and their
judgment muscle.
And all decision should
be made as a
combination of those things.
And right now we sort of have a
lot of high priests of data.
And there's a lot of ways that
data can lie just like
statistics can lie.
And just like I'm in
the media business.
And for a long time, we didn't
think photographs can lie.
Photographs are among the most
famous liars in history.
So you want to keep
that in mind.
And then, I think we
should wrap up
and ask some questions.
What do you think?
HUGH THOMPSON: Yeah.
Yeah sure.
Well, I'll just go to this
last public service
announcement.
BOB SULLIVAN: Please do.
That's important.
HUGH THOMPSON: Now
before we leave.
And this is related to
the data problem.
And, again, it's coming
up summer.
Many people are considering
a vacation,
somewhere tropical to go.
Just wanted to let you know that
there's a very serious
issue occurring out there
in the world called
Sharkmageddon.
Now I don't know if
you've seen this.
But there's been a dramatic
increase in
worldwide shark attacks.
If you look at the headlines
that came out of this increase
a couple years ago, you've got
this one from MSNBC.com.
BOB SULLIVAN: A very important
news service.
HUGH THOMPSON: But note the
exceptionally scary
picture of a shark.
Shark attacks rose 25% last
year across the globe.
"LA Times," a more docile
looking shark.
But still concerning.
"Huffington Post," they've got
people closing beaches signs
going up about these
shark attacks.
BOB SULLIVAN: 25% again.
HUGH THOMPSON: 25%.
BOB SULLIVAN: It's huge.
HUGH THOMPSON: Really serious.
That's a big increase man.
That's like "The Birds" but
for sharks or something.
I don't know.
But if you look behind the
numbers, it's fascinating.
The number of shark attacks
worldwide, so this is for
every person who went
in the ocean in 2010
went from 63% to 79%.
BOB SULLIVAN: That is 25%.
HUGH THOMPSON: It is 25%.
I agree.
But your personal chances of
getting bitten by a shark are
less than you being hit by a
buss painted like a shark on
the way to the beach.
And statistically--
and I'm statistician.
BOB SULLIVAN: That's
very-- yeah.
Yeah.
HUGH THOMPSON: And it's
interesting much of the
increase was due to two very
angry sharks in Egypt.
BOB SULLIVAN: Who were
responsible for 12 or 13 of
the attacks or something.
HUGH THOMPSON: Which
proves something
we've known all along.
One shark can make
a difference.
Sorry, I had to throw that.
Sorry.
But yeah, we would like to leave
time to talk a little
bit about this.
And, of course, there's a lot
more in the book around what
these specific areas
are that cause
plateaus and lead to plateaus.
BOB SULLIVAN: And hopefully how
they can help you in what
you're doing here or at
home or trying to
learn how to play guitar.
I know there's some
books in the back.
We're happy to hang around
too and sign some
books if you want to.
But thank you for all of your
attention, and we'd love to
take some questions now.
Apparently there's two
microphones on
either side of the back.
And they are recording it, so it
would be best if you could
walk up to the microphone
and ask your question.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for your talk.
I really enjoyed it.
So I find it persuasive the way
you present as far as an
individual's growth that we
all reach these plateaus.
And we have to take these
other measures to
change things up.
Switch to from one profession
or attempt to another.
But it seems like there's
another side of the coin,
which is somebody maybe spends
20 years in a profession doing
something, becomes the greatest
treadmill runner,
they may not grow as much, but
they'll be better at their job
than someone else.
So is there a way to combine
the best of both?
BOB SULLIVAN: I think that's
a really great point.
And in our time right
now, you're talking
about mastery, right?
And this is sort of the 10,000
hours thing that Malcolm
Gladwell always talks about.
It takes 10,000 hours, by the
way, I always compute this in
my head, is basically 10
years, of hard work.
So it takes 10 years to
get good at something.
And we live in this economy now
where we tend to get rid
of people who then are
good at things.
So I absolutely think
that you're right.
We are talking about one
half of this equation.
So I'm a musician so I talk
about this a lot.
If you're a classical guitarist,
and you've topped
out in where you're going, one
of the best things you can do
is take six months and plug
in and play rock and roll.
Teaches some whole
new techniques.
It stimulates other parts
of the brain.
And that's one of the ways that
you can move forward.
I am very personally concerned
about what you're saying
though, which is if you are a
master in your field, we don't
really, I think, regard mastery
just like we kind of
don't regard age in the United
States in a lot of situations.
Right?
So maybe he's giving us an
idea for our next book.
HUGH THOMPSON: Oh, yeah.
A sequel.
BOB SULLIVAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
No, but I think the lesson that
our book would have for
someone in that situation is you
don't have to necessarily,
like the music example
I just gave you.
We're not saying that a fireman
should go try to be a
software engineer.
But we're saying that within
your discipline, there are
ways for you to try very,
very new things.
And it's funny, if you look at
food and you look at music,
fusion is actually the trend
in almost all of these
disciplines.
So like Indian, and I mean
Indian subcontinent, jazz, for
example, is really popular
in alternative
music for right now.
So musical fusions.
And restaurants, I go to
restaurants all the
time now that are--
well, you see this a lot
in the Latin community.
They'll be Spanish restaurants
that have ceviche from Latin
America, for example.
Or even Korean restaurants that
are integrating some of
this Latin American flavors.
And so combining talents, I
think, is really where people
can and not necessarily
abandoning fields they're in,
but plucking out things from
brand new fields and applying
them to what they're doing
right now is probably the
fastest way to accelerate even
if you are sort of stuck at
the high end of that
plateau curve.
HUGH THOMPSON: And just add
something to that, I think
there's areas in your life where
you want to be a master.
If you're writing Java code or
C-sharp, probably Java you
know that's fine.
If you're writing code then
every incremental improvement
even if it's small compared
to where you were is good.
Because that's an area where
you want to have mastery.
There's so many other areas of
our lives though where we just
want to get to a level
that's good enough.
And the question is to move
from good enough to master
that might be a 10 year gap.
But to move from nothing to good
enough might be a very
small amount of time.
So the question is which areas
in your life do you want
mastery and which areas in your
life do you want to get
to that point?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
HUGH THOMPSON: Great.
Thanks.
BOB SULLIVAN: Thanks
for the question.
HUGH THOMPSON: Questions?
BOB SULLIVAN: This curious room
full of Googlers, there
must be questions.
HUGH THOMPSON: Comments?
Personal issues at home you'd
like to share in a supportive
group of other peers?
BOB SULLIVAN: Don't ever get
on an airplane with him.
HUGH THOMPSON: No.
Dude, I'm sworn off
of that stuff.
BOB SULLIVAN: Well, if there's
no questions, we'll just hang
around the back and then
may be we can take them
individually or sign
some books.
Thanks again for your time.
HUGH THOMPSON: Thanks a lot.
Appreciate it.